we're gonna give to this next and I
respect you I want you guys to yell at
each other for three minutes why go pee
I got a p2 okay we'll do in [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'll go first okay anyways you are
someone that I could talk to about the
flat earth conspiracy you don't believe
in Flat Earth but you can kind of
understand where I'm coming from if I
financed a research ship or in orbit
okay you raise the money we're gonna do
this we're gonna do this you're gonna
find the edge of the world with my
iPhone we're gonna send someone else you
blame me course I believe that we went
into a long conversation we played I
heard it is so crazy that I always
thought I was so tough doesn't have to
pee anymore that is the point is the
point is is that why are we debating
whether the earth is flat dude they're
keeping they have human-animal hybrids
[Music]